- It's beauty junky time.
Having beauty rituals
and consistency together
is what's really important.
And that's why I'm excited
that we've teamed up with Olay
to discuss morning and nighttime rituals
for a special segment we're calling
good morning and goodnight.
(crowd cheering)
And joining us is the
authority of all things beauty.
Editor and chief of Allure magazine,
my friend, Michelle Lee.
(crowd cheering)
- Hey Drew.
- Oh hi Michelle.
- Hi.
- How are ya?
- I'm good thank you, I'm
miss seeing you in person.
- I know, I'm so cranking
out to just see you.
It makes me so happy,
although I'm always watching
all of your videos.
So I do feel connected to
you, thanks to social media.
And I really respect, I mean,
I call myself a beauty junkie
but you are like at the
top of the mountain,
as far as I'm concerned, I bow
down to your beauty knowledge
and I loved the subject of this.
The good morning and good night
had such a romanticism to me.
So okay, when you wake up,
what is your good morning?
- Yes, so as you know,
I had a baby recently.
I've got a 15 year old a 12 year old
and now an eight month old.
Once I get her kind of settled,
I then start my skincare.
I think now that I've gotten the baby
I've simplified it a little
bit, but always cleansing,
absolutely doing like a gentle cleanser.
I then start to layer things.
So I'll do an essence, some sort of serums
and then also vitamin C.
So vitamin C every single morning
whether it's in a serum
or in a moisturizer.
I've been using the Olay
vitamin C from Regenerist.
This one is super great.
I find it really hydrating.
I also love that there's
no fragrance in it.
Vitamin C is just like
that powerhouse ingredient
of where it's really great
for hyperpigmentation,
for overall skin brightness.
I am obsessed.
- I had moved to Alaska for
four months to make a film
and we were filming it in winter.
And that is when I started
using Regenerist very loyally.
It saved me from sitting outside
for 12 hours in zero degree weather
in the driest of conditions.
And that's when I became an Olay loyalist.
Okay, Michelle, we've
done the morning routine.
Now, what is your evening ritual?
- I usually start the
baby's bedtime routine.
And then once the baby is asleep
I start my nighttime skincare routine.
Nighttime skincare routine is
a little bit more pared down.
I do the Korean double cleanse.
I usually put on a couple
of different serums
and then I'll end with a retinol.
- And this one I love
because it's just gentle and hydrating.
- Exactly, I am totally loving
this retinal 24 by Olay.
It is super hydrating and
it's such a good price
for this like powerhouse ingredient.
So retinol is basically vitamin A.
So if you think about like the
vitamin A foods that we eat,
like carrots and you know,
sweet potatoes and stuff,
it's that same compound.
So it's also a vitamin that it really
penetrates deep into your skin
and it helps to stimulate cell turnover.
So it's very different from vitamin C,
but they also both kind
of help with skin tone
and brightening as well.
So, that's why I use retinol at night
and vitamin C during the day.
- Okay, Allure has a new
podcast launching this week
and I've been a guest on
the Allure podcast before.
And will tell me about it?
- I will, so it was so
nice having you as a guest
on the Allure podcast when
I could see you in person.
But yes, we have one launching this week
called the science of beauty,
which we're doing in
partnership with Olay.
And so I'm co-hosting it with our
executive beauty director Jenny Byee.
And so every episode we go into one topic,
like sunscreen, pores,
pigmentation, wrinkles,
vitamins, and we're
talking to a lot of doctors
and just diving deep into different myths,
answering a lot of questions.
And I know a lot about
skincare and about ingredients
but I feel like I've learned so much
just from recording these episodes.
- Michelle I just started salivating.
I'm not kidding.
My saliva glands just
like started in overdrive,
because as a beauty junkie, enthusiast,
self-proclaimed and you on
the mountain top of knowledge,
the science behind things,
I will be an avid listener.
And I'm so glad I cannot
wait to listen to this.
So these products are available
at Target and Target.com.
And guess what?
All of today's VFS are gonna home
with a $50 gift card from Target.
(crowd cheering)
So, you could Olay and then some.
And I just really want
to thank Michelle who,
really, we are so lucky to be speaking
with someone of her
caliber and her knowledge.
And I am gonna be hooked
on that podcast day one.
Thank you Michelle so
much for being with us.
- Thank you, thank you
so much for having me.
- Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)